hey David this is from Adam David how
good for the environment are solar
panels and do we recycle them yeah this
this is that's a question that has come
up before the idea is so like with so
with electric vehicles there was a
question well ok the car runs on
electricity
but you need carbon to make the battery
and then you're still charging the
battery with electricity that comes from
fossil fuels like coal for example or
natural gas and then the battery needs
to either be recycled or put in a
landfill so is it really better to have
an electric car than a gas-powered car
and the answer was well yes it is and we
don't need to get into the numbers of
that right now there's a similar
question about solar panels the solar
panels receive solar energy which is
renewable in a sense of eventually the
Sun will burn out but for practical
terms it's renewable but you need to
make the solar panels that has a carbon
footprint they need to be shipped what
happens after the solar panels are no
longer good so this is knowable
information solar panels are primarily
made from silicon silicon comes from
quartz it's mined and heated and there
is some carbon dioxide immediate emitted
into the atmosphere during that process
the majority of the footprint of solar
panels is in manufacturing
once it's done there is very little in
the way of emissions Manufacturing is
going to become more and more efficient
over time but even if we account for the
current level of manufacturing emissions
for solar panels the carbon footprint
per gigawatt hour is very low compared
to gas and coal the the there's actually
similar as I mentioned with electric
cars if the electricity comes from coal
what about that well that will be
changed if you're burning gasoline
you're burning gasoline if you are using
electricity you can over time clean up
the source of that electricity with the
recyclability of solar panels in short
yes they can be recycled and reused the
materials are used the materials used
are by and large recyclable whether they
are recycled is a different question it
doesn't always happen but
aluminum and solar panels is 100%
reusable the glass is 95% reusable you
can evaporate the small plastic
components to separate the solar cells
and the silicon wafers and then smelt
and reuse those about 85% reusable and
it also has to be accounted for in the
calculus of the carbon footprint that
recycling also uses energy and there's
math behind all of this and it's maybe
exceeds the scope of this segment but
even accounting for all of that carbon
footprint it's not perfectly efficient
but it is way better than what we have
and it's really important not to let
people who are just haphazardly and
reflexively defending the use of fossil
fuels say well there's a carbon
footprint to making and transporting and
then recycling the solar panels yes of
course there is but it is far smaller
than that in terms of the energy
produced as measured per gigawatt hour
than coal or gas or anything else know
the information
don't fall for just random talking
points that might make sense or might
not because when we look for the answers
we can typically find them we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
get instant access to it by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show